what are you down about what are you
feeling it's just hard to think about
the end kris jenner isn't ready to say
goodbye
in a new sneak peek of keeping up with
the kardashians final season
chris has an emotional chat with pals
cal richards and faye resnick
what else is happening it's part of our
life
like this is our life but why are you
saying
i don't want to see you cry as
supportive boyfriend corey gamble goes
on to explain
chris has been feeling down about the
show's 14th season being its last
the queen the little sweet little baby
little lady from la jolla
has been down down and y'all need to
talk to her about a show ending because
she's really been down
about that it's just hard to think about
the
end i want to know after
what you give all of us with your show
why would you stop
i don't understand for the 65 year old
momager
decisions about the series ending all
came down to family
is very complicated with so many people
it is it is complicated
there's so many and it's it's all these
different personalities and people
and kids and grandkids and everybody and
thinking what's the right thing for
everybody and
when's the right moment it's been
incredibly
challenging incredibly hard in a
previous trailer we saw kim in tears as
she addressed the show's crew
i just want you to know what they really
appreciate you guys each and every one
of you
and here we also see chris taking a
moment to applaud the show's
behind-the-scenes family
and everybody in this room is my family
these are my family i know they are and
they're day one season one thank you
baby
every single thing we've ever done we've
done together
telling the crew was the hardest thing
i've ever done in my whole life
like to say you know this might be the
last season
because we love each other so much
and i appreciate all you guys just for
the record
[Music]
last year caitlyn jenner told et she
thinks the family might be a little
quote
relieved the series is coming to an end
i talked to all the kids i talked to kim
yesterday i talked to him
and you know they have done
such a magnificent job and taking that
show
and building their own careers outside
of the show
and they use that format so well that
there's a
million things to do you know
and so i think in some ways they might
be a little bit relieved
that you know it's it's over with but on
the other hand
it was such a great format for the
entire family
we'll all we'll always miss that
you